سبير او البديل وهذا الاسم اختاره تحديدا
الامير هاري عنوان لكتابه الجديد اريد
الذي يبلغ من العمر 38 عاما يرى نفسه
بديلا لمن لاخيه الاكبر ويليام الاخواني
باتا خصمين بوصف هاري بيحدداته في كتابه
الكتاب هو الطاغي على الاوساط في المملكه
المتحده الان لانه ابرز كتاب يتناول
العائله الملكيه منذ نشر والده هاري
الاميره ديانا هارت روستوريا عام 1990
والكتاب بصفحاته ال 500 المنشوره وصفحاته
ال 400 المحذوفه ولغته 16 التي ترجم اليها
بنسخته الصوتيه بات الان في الاسواق بعد
تسريبات ومقابلات حوله لكن لماذا اثار كل
هذا الجدل
هذه يكشف في الكتاب كواليس ما دار منذ
تخليه عن مهامه الملكيه في عام 2020 بعد
زواجه بعمل من الممثله الامريكيه مدام
ماركل وانتقالهما الى كاليفورنيا لبدا
حياه جديده
[موسيقى]